[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour cette émission
spéciale consacrée aux paris saclay
spring c'était la cinquième édition elle
s'est tenue en présentiel deux jours
donc dédié au meilleur de l'innovation
de jours pour que tous les acteurs du
secteur qui soit investisseurs
entrepreneurs chercheurs puissent se
retrouver ici à l'école polytechnique et
d'ailleurs vous allez entendre dans
quelques instants son président éric la
baille à leur programme des rencontres
les rendez vous b to be be to fit des
conférences avec des ambassadeurs
prestigieux le spring 50 ce concours qui
distingue les 50 meilleures startups du
territoire un plateau télévisé aussi qui
a permis de suivre l'événement nous
avons été dans les coulisses nous allons
aussi vous faire visiter les villages et
les circuits de l'innovation l'occasion
rare de pénétrer dans les laboratoires
des grands groupes et vous allez voir
donc que les principaux sujets de notre
société la foutait clé mobilité les
technologies numériques la green tech et
la santé biotech sont au coeur de la
recherche sont au coeur de la tech
alleanza
[Musique]
nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
aujourd'hui ce prime harry saclay sa
cinquième édition à l'école
polytechnique au coeur du campus de
l'institut politique de paris c'était un
formidable témoignage de la vivacité de
la dynamique en cours de l'innovation
sur le plateau de paris-saclay puisque
nous avons ici 50 start up qui sont
représentés et elle témoigne donc dû eux
tout le travail qui est fait entre les
différents acteurs du plateau les
institutions d'enseignement et de
recherche comme ip paris lui verser de
paris-saclay les bien entendu les
laboratoires des entreprises également
le soutien des collectivités locales de
la région de l'état et tous cette
connexion ces rencontres et bien on fait
développer une innovation qui
travaillent en plus sur les grands
sujets sociétaux puisqu'aujourd'hui on
parle de greentech par le biotech
agritech on parle de nos produits de
tout ce qui est le développement du
digital pour apporter de meilleurs
services aux citoyens et donc c'est un
formidable bouillonnement d'idées donc
très heureux que ceux ci aient lieu
cette année à l'école piqué
on
[Musique]
pourquoi
on
fecteau nous sommes une société qui a
une plateforme avec les bouts de mettre
en relation des investisseurs avec des
intervenants dans les domaines des
technologies innovantes c'est à dire
dans les domaines de la santé du digital
de soutenabilité chaque maire de
lectoure organise plus de 25 programmes
et événements qui mettent en relation
une milice tissot avec 1000 et de
preneurs dans ce domaine avec moi dans
le but d'aider les entrepreneurs à
développer la stratégie et d'élever les
fonds et en même temps on aide les
investisseurs à trouver les scuds
d'excellence des différents systèmes
écosystèmes européenne on en a eu la
possibilité hier aujourd'hui au spring
aussi de le faire découvrir les
investisseurs de notre de notre réseau
l'excellence française qu'ils ont
retrouvé ici
[Musique]
le groupe ratp très heureux d'être
ambassadeur de la partie mobilité du
paris saclay spring c'est une action qui
correspond à 2 nos grandes priorités la
première c'est l'innovation
le plateau de saclay c'est un vrai
territoire d'innovation on a déjà de
nombreux partenariats avec des start up
instituts de recherche des écoles ici
sur le sur le plateau et un salon comme
celui ci c'est l'occasion d'en nouer de
nouveaux et puis c'est aussi un axe de
notre action de développement
territorial donc la ratp vient de gagner
le marché d'exploitation du réseau de
transport du plateau de saclay et donc
en fait c'est aussi une manière pour
nous de mieux connaître le territoire et
de travailler avec ces acteurs chose
qu'on fait bien sûr ici mais également
dans toutes les villes où on est on est
implanté on a cette volonté de
travailler localement avec les acteurs
parce qu'on est persuadé que c'est
souvent localement pour trouver les
meilleures solutions aux problématiques
de mobilité
[Musique]
on s'arrête maintenant sur l'un des
temps forts de paris saclay spring les
circuits de l'innovation les grands
groupes présents sur votre territoire
comme edf servier safran ou encore total
énergie et bien d'autres ont accepté
d'ouvrir les portes de leurs
laboratoires
c'est une occasion rare
nous on vous emmène chez jc des causses
est un groupe spécialisé dans la
publicité urbaine vous avez forcément vu
leur grand panneau et bien je vous
propose une visite guidée de leur média
lab regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jc decaux et partenaires de
l'établissement public de paris-saclay
depuis 2010 9 en tant que grands groupes
français fortement implanté sur le
territoire et en engagement permanent
avec les collectivités nous semblait
normal d'être un partenaire et notamment
de saclay spring encore une fois cette
année nous avons effectivement été
ambassadeur de l'édition 2022 pour
pouvoir profiter de cet événement
international sur l'un des plus beaux
kloster mondiaux pour nous abreuver de
deux thématiques autour de la smart
cities de la mobilité et des
technologies digitales dans le cadre de
notre politique d'open innovation nous
recherchons toujours à approfondir et à
tirer le meilleur de nos partenariats
avec l'écosystème et c'est pour ça que
nous avons souhaité participer encore
une fois à paris saclay spring 2022 pour
nous cela revêt trois grands objectifs
le premier qui est de créer des liens
avec l'écosystème de rencontrer des
partenaires et des projets potentiels
projets de recherche ensuite de
positionner jc decaux comme un acteur
leader de l'innovation en montrant notre
engagement auprès des start up mais
également en nous permettant de nous
adresser
au public d'étudiants du plateau dans le
cadre d'une politique de marque
employeur et de recrutement c'est aussi
un événement qui est très important pour
nous pour fédérer en interne puisque sur
paris saclay spring on a plusieurs
équipes qui sont venus intervenir les
équipes r&d production et opérations les
équipes communication mais également les
équipes nouveaux usages et data
nous avons eu plusieurs formats
d'intervention cette année déjà notre
directrice recherche et production
il est intervenu en cadre de ce prix de
50 qui est le concours de startups dédié
à trouver les meilleures startups du
plateau notre directeur data corp est
intervenu lors d'une conférence sur les
enjeux de la démocratisation de la data
et enfin nous avons pu ouvrir nos portes
sur notre site de plaisir sainte
apolline dans ce cadre notre parc
exposition pour faire découvrir nos
nouveaux produits et services et comment
est ce que nous envisageons les
conditions d'une vie plus agréable et
plus durable en vilain
2022 est encore une très belle édition
et nous remercions notre partenaire
l'établissement public de paris-saclay
pour ce joli coup de projecteur jeter
sur les start up française et les grands
groupes français avec une portée
internationale
voilà pour cette spéciale paris saclay
spring notre agenda à présent si vous
avez raté les circuits de l'innovation
et que vous rêvez de découvrir l'edf lab
participer au vendredi de la recherche
edf labs propose des visites guidées
avec un conférencier autre rendez-vous
les assises du numérique elles se
tiendront le 1er juin à port marly une
journée rythmée par des tables rondes
sur le numérique pour l'éducation les
territoires et bâtiments connectés la
e-santé la cyber sécurité là aussi il
faut s'inscrire autre rendez-vous le
paris saclay connexion lifesize
courtaboeuf c'est le 2 juin de 11h à 14h
aux ulis juste pour rappel le parc
d'activités de courtaboeuf est le
premier parc d'activités tertiaires en
europe vous risquez donc de rencontrer
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et en termine
avec du sport et le nord dit trahi
running trois courses au coeur des
jardins du château de versailles c'est
royal etc le 19 juin vous avez encore un
peu de temps pour vous entraîner et
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci d'être fidèle à paris
saclay tv on se retrouve très vite pour
un prochain numéro mais d'ici là restez
informés grâce au site ep à tirer paris
saclay point fr à bientôt
[Musique]